Picard this is what is this season three
yeah season three the final season of
Picard yeah right
what can you tell us the biggest secret
it's been shown it's done they've aired
it was yes with data data I always say
that I know I love it it's a huge reveal
well there were lots of reveals
the what's your favorite
real besides data
no the reveals were all over the place
it's the fact that I had a son that
Picard didn't know about it was his son
that's the biggest reveal that is the
biggest reveal that was the biggest one
when you read that were you like oh my
god well I knew that it was there
because if it hadn't been an interesting
storyline I don't think I would have
done it I think that might be true for
several of us but
um because the parts have been pretty
much nothing for my character in the
movies it was just like you know yeah
well right we got to put it in a couple
that's gotta be so annoying
disappointing I mean they'll pay you
yeah it's annoying isn't the word but it
is
a part of it again it goes back to the
thing it's it's for me it's not about
I mean I'm sure there's there's
tremendous ego I'm sure all sorts of
things but I know for me
I am happiest I don't care whether I'm
directing at that night at the 99 seat
theater 100 seat theater in Atwater
Village
I forget to eat I forget I'm hungry I
forget if it's the process I get into
the process I really do I mean it's not
I really do love it I don't
care if it's
teaching it's watching the people get it
you know I don't feel like you're a real
part of the process you don't you feel
that's like sort of
bored
you feel well bored or disappointed or
you feel ancillary you're just not it's
not very important and then you go well
okay people go well they yeah I'm doing
this and they're paying me that much and
I don't It's Tricky you know I would
much rather feel really great about the
part of what it is or be challenged in
some way but I do love the show I do I
do I think it's I mean and I've learned
how to love it I didn't watch Star Trek
I didn't watch Star Wars either I mean I
didn't have a TV when I lived in New
York I know seriously but I think
um
Oh by meeting the fans we I've met some
really interesting people and you you
learn about the economy and the
socioeconomic situation of the United
States of America when you go to these
places